welcome to deep learning interview
questions my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that's w w
simply learn comm get certified get
ahead today we're gonna help you prepare
for interview questions dealing with
deep learning and we're gonna go from
the very basics of neural networks and
deep learning into some of the more
commonly used models so she can have
understanding of what kind of questions
are gonna come up and what you need to
know in interview questions we'll start
with a very general concept of what is
deep learning this is where we take
large volumes of data in this case on
cats and dogs or whatever a lot of times
you use a training set up to train your
model remember it's not like a magic
black box going on there then we use
that to extract features or extract
information and in this case classify
the image of a cat and a dog so the
primary ticularly we're talking about
deep learning is it learns from large
volumes of structured and even
unstructured data and uses complex
algorithms to train neural network it
also performs complex operations to
extract hidden patterns and features and
if we're gonna discuss deep learning in
this very simplified overview and we
also have to go over what is a neural
network this is a common image you'll
see of a drawing of a forward
propagation neural network and it's it's
a human brain inspired system which
replicate the way humans learn so this
is inspired how our own neurons in our
brain fire but at a much simplified
level obviously it's not ready to take
over the human population and be our
leader yet not for many years it's very
much in its infant stage but it's
inspired by how our brains work I think
use a lot of other inspirations you can
study brains of moths and other animals
that they be used to figure out how to
improve these neural networks the most
common one consists of three layers of
network and this is generally how you
view these networks is you have an input
you have a hidden layer and an output
and the neural network is broken up into
many pieces but we focused just on the
neural network it's always on the hidden
layers that we're making all the
adjustments and figuring out how to best
set up those hidden layers for their
functions to both train faster and a
function better when we look at this of
course we have our input hidden output
each layer contains neurons called as
notes perform various operations and you
can see here we have the list of the
nose we have both our input nodes and
our output notes and then our hidden
layer notes and it's used in deep
learning algorithm like CNN RN ngan etc
well address some of these models a
little closer at least the most common
models as we go down the list and we
study the deep learning and the neural
network framework let's start with what
is a multi-layer perceptron or MLP a lot
of time as it referred to and you'll see
these abbreviations I'll be honest I
have to write them down on a piece of
paper and go through them so I never
remember what they all mean
even though I play with them all the
time what is a multi-layer perceptron
well if you look at the image on the
right it's very similar to what we just
looked at you have your input layer your
hidden layer and your output layer and
that's exactly what this is it has the
same structure of a single layer
perceptron with one or more hidden
layers except the input layer each node
and the other layers uses a nonlinear
activation function what that means is
your input layers your data coming in
and then your activation function is
based upon all those nodes and weights
being added together and then it has the
output MLP uses supervised learning
method called back propagation for
training the model very key word there
is back propagation single layer
perceptron can classify only linear
separable classes with binary output 0 1
but the MLP can classify nonlinear
classes so let's break this down just a
little bit the multi-layer perceptron
with an input layer and a hidden layer
and an output layer as you see that it
comes in there it has ads up all the
numbers and weights depending on how
your setup is that thing goes to the
next layer that thing goes to the next
hidden layer if you have multiple hidden
layers and finally to the output layer
the back propagation takes the error
that it sees so whatever the output is
it says hey this has an error too it's
wrong and it sends that error backwards
from where it came from and there's a
lot of different functions used to train
this based on that error and how that
error goes backwards in the notes so
forward is you get your answers backward
is for training you see this every day
even my Google pixel phone has this if
they train the neural network which
takes a lot more data to Train than it
does to
use and then they load up that neural
network into in this case I have a pixel
- which actually has a built in neural
network for processing pictures and so
it's just a forward propagation I use
when it processes my photos but when
they were training it used the back
propagation to Train it with the errors
they had will be coming back to
different models that are used for right
now though multi-layer perceptron MLP
but that devan's your vocabulary word
and of course back propagation what is
data normalization and why do we need it
this is so important we spend so much
time in normalizing our data and getting
our data clean and setting it up so we
talk about data there's a pre-processing
step to standardize the data so whatever
we have coming in we don't want it to be
a one gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a 3 kilobyte text there
even as a human I can't process those
all in the same group I have to reformat
them in some way that loops them
together so the standardized format we
use this data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or the same
information in different formats then we
want to rescale values to fit into a
particular range for achieving better
convergence what this means is with most
neural networks they form a bias we've
seen this in recently in attacks on
neural networks where they light up one
pixel or one piece of the view and it
skews the whole answer so suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do well when we
start rescaling it we put our other
values between say -1 and 1 and we
change them and refit them to those
values it helps get rid of that bias
helps fix for some of those problems and
then finally we restructure the data and
improve the integrity we want to make
sure that we're not missing values or we
don't have partial data coming in one
way to look at this is bad data in bad
data out so we want clean data in and
you want good answers coming out one of
the most basic models used is a
Boltzmann machine so let's address what
is a Boltzmann machine and if you know
we just did the MLP multi-layer
perceptrons so now we're going to
into almost a simplified version of that
and in this we have our visible input
layer and we have our hidden layer the
Boltzmann machines are almost always
shallow they're usually just two layer
neural nets that make stochastic
decisions whether a neuron should be on
or off
true/false yes/no first layer is a
visible layer and second layer is the
hidden layer nodes are connected to each
other across layers but no two nodes of
the same layer are connected hence it is
also known as restricted Boltzmann
machine now that we've covered a basic
MLP or multi-layer perceptron and we've
gone over the Boltzmann machine also
known as the restricted Boltzmann
machine let's talk a little bit about
activation formulas and this is a huge
topic that can get really complicated
but it also is automated so it's very
simple so you have both a complicated
and a simple at the same time so what is
the role of activation functions in a
neural network activation function
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not that's the most basic one and
that actually changes a little bit
because it's either weather fired or not
in this case activation function or what
value should come out when it's fired
but in these models we're looking at
just the Boltzmann restricted layers so
this is what causes them to fire either
they don't or they do it's a yes-or-no
true/false
all-or-nothing it accepts the weighted
sum of the inputs the bias as input to
any activation function so whatever our
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on the
model let's just go back to the model
real quick and then you always have to
add a bias and you can look at the bias
if you remember from your Euclidean
geometry you draw a straight line
formula for that line has a y-coordinate
at the end it's always CX plus M or
something like that where M is where it
crosses the y coordinates if you're
doing a straight line with these weights
it's very similar but a lot of times we
just add it in as its own weight we take
it as a node of a1 value coming in and
then we compute its new weight and
that's how we compute that bias just
like we compute all the other weights
coming in the node which gets fires
depends on the Y value and then we have
a step function and this depth function
this is where I remember I said is going
to get complicated and simple all the
same
we have a lot of different step
functions we have the sigmoid function
we have just a standard step function we
have the Ray Lou it's pronounced like
ray the rim from the Sun and Lou like a
name so ray Lou function and we have the
tangent H function and if you look at
these they all have something similar
they all either force it to be one value
or the other they force it to be in the
case of the first three is zero or one
and in the last one it's either a minus
one or one and you can easily convert
that to a zero one yes/no true/false and
on this one of the most common ones is
the step function itself because there
is no middle value there is no
discrepancy in this says I'm not quite
sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
to be the sigmoid was most commonly used
but I you see the Ray Lou used more
often really depending on what you're
doing you just have to play with these
and find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only 0.6 not a 1 and even though the
1 is what's going into the next neural
network or the next hidden layer as an
input the 0.6 value might also be going
in there to let you know hey this is not
a straight-up one or straight-up 0 as
someplace in the middle this is a little
uncertain what's coming out here so it's
a very powerful tool but the basic
neural network you usually just use the
step function it's yes or no let's take
a big step back and take a kind of an
overview the next function is what is a
cost function and we're gonna cover this
is so important because this is your end
result that you're gonna do over and
over again and use to decide whether the
model is working or not whether you need
to try a different step function whether
you need to try a different activation
whether you need to try a fully
different model used so what is the cost
function cost function is a measure to
evaluate how good your models
performance is it is also referred to as
loss or error used to compute the error
of the output layer during back
there's our backpropagation when we're
training our model that's one of our key
words mean squared error is an example
of a popular cost function and so here
we have the cost function C equals half
of Y minus y predicted and then you
square that so the first thing is you
know real quick if you haven't done
statistics this is not a percentage it's
not a percentage of how accurate it is
it's just a measurement of the error and
we take that error for training it we
push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training X it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the Train one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for training and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we got to look at both
the local and the global setup it might
work great to test your data on what you
have on your computer but that's
different than in the field so when
we're talking about all these different
tests in the error test as far as your
loss you don't you want to make sure
that you're in a closed environment when
you do your initial testing but you also
want to open that up and make sure you
follow up with the testing on the larger
scale of data because it will change it
might not fit the larger scale there
might be something in there and the way
you brought the data in specifically or
the data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error just one other side note on
a lot of the newer models of neural
networks by comparing the error we get
on the data our training data with a
portion of the test data we can actually
figure out how good the model is whether
it's over fitted or not we'll go into
that a little bit more as we go into
some of the different models so we have
our output we're able to figure out the
error on it based on the square means
usually although there's other functions
used so we want to talk about what is
gradient descent another vocabulary word
gradient descent is an optimal algorithm
to minimize the cost function or to
minimize the error aim is to find the
local
global minima of a function determine
the direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data I just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well you could
be that you're looking at just that line
of that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
costs of each piece of data coming in
and figure out the global one how we're
gonna adjust this model to fit all the
data we don't want it to be biased just
on three or four lines of data coming in
we wanted to kind of extrapolate a
general answer for all the data coming
in this of course we mentioned it
briefly about back propagation this is
where it really comes in handy is
training our model neural network
technique to minimize the cost function
helps to improve the performance of the
network back propagates the error and
updates the waste to reduce the error so
as you can see here is a very nice
depiction of a back propagation we have
our predicted Y coming out and then we
have since it's a training set we
already know the answer and the answer
comes back and based on case the square
means was one of the functions we looked
at one of the activation functions based
on cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them well change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error that
still being carried back it'll change
the weights going to the next hidden
layer and then it computes an error
level on that and sends that back up and
you're gonna say well if it computes the
error into the first hidden layer and
fixes it why would it stop there well
remember we don't want to create a
biased neural network so we only make
small adjustments on these weights we
don't make a big adjustment that changes
everything right off the bat so no
matter how far back you go you're always
gonna have a small amount of error
and they're still gonna continue to go
all the way back up to hidden layers for
right now focus on the backpropagation
is taking that error and moving it
backwards on the neural network to
change the weights and help program it
so that it'll have the correct answers
so far we've been talking about forward
propagation neural networks everything
goes forwards goes left to right but
this this thing a little deterrent let's
see what is the difference between a
feed-forward neural network and a
recurrent neural network now this is in
the function not when we're training it
using the back propagation so you've got
new information coming in and you want
to get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there we want to
know we have a feed-forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a
feed-forward neural network signals
travel in one direction from input to
output no feedback loops considers only
the current input cannot memorize
previous inputs one example of one of
these feed-forward neural networks and
we've covered a number of them but one
of the ones this has a big highlight
nowadays is the CN n a convolutional
neural network tensorflow the one put
out by Google is probably most known for
their CN n where the information goes
forward it first takes a picture splits
it apart goes through the individual
pixels on the picture so it picks up a
different reading then calculates based
on that goes into a regular feed-forward
neural network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the CN n today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
CN n is a forward propagation neural
network all night so it's only moving in
one direction so we will look at a
recurrent neural network signals travel
in both directions making it a looped
network considers the current input
along with the previous received inputs
for generating the output of a layer has
the ability to memorize past data due to
its internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our input
for some reason they always do the
recurrent neural network in Reverse from
bottom up in the images kind of a
standard although I'm not sure why your
X goes into
your hidden lair and your hidden lair
the answer for part of the answer from
that it generates feeds back into the
hidden lair so now you have an input of
both X and part of the hint lair and
then that feeds into your output now if
we go back to the forward let me just go
back a slide and we're looking at our
forward propagation Network one of the
tricks you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a time sequence that's a
good term to remember or a time series
meaning that a sequential data each term
comes after the other you can trick this
by creating your input nodes as with the
history so if you know that you have
values 1 5 and 7 going in and you know
what the output is from 1 what those
outputs are you can expand the input to
include the history input that's one of
the ways to trick a forward propagation
network into looking at that but when
you do with an recurrent neural network
you let the hidden layer do that for you
it sends that data and reprocesses it
back into itself what are some of the
applications of recurrent neural network
the RNN can be used for sentiment
analysis and text mining getting up
early in the morning is good for health
and it's a positive sentiment one of the
catches you really want to look at this
when you're looking at the language is
that I could switch this around and
totally negate the meaning of what I'm
doing so we'd no longer be positive so
when you're looking at a sentence
knowing the order of the words is as
important as the meaning of the words
you can't just count how many good words
there are versus bad words to get a some
positive sentiment you now have to know
what they're addressing and there's lots
of other different uses kids are playing
football or soccer as we call it in the
u.s. our n can help you capture an image
so based on previous information coming
in and refeeds that back in and you have
a image Center and then time series
problems like predicting the prices of
stocks in a month or quarter or sell a
products can be solved using an RNN and
this is a really good example you have
whatever your stocks were doing earlier
this month will have a huge effect on
what they're doing today if you're
investing so having an RNN model a
recurrent neural network feeding into
itself what was happening previously
allows it to take that model and program
in the whole series without having to
put in the hole a month at a time of
data you'd only put in one day at a time
but if you keep them in order it will
look back and say oh this because what
happened yesterday I need some
information from that and I'm gonna use
that to help predict today's and so on
and so on we're gonna go back to our
activation functions remember I told you
Raley was one of the most common
functions used so let's talk a little
bit more about Ray Lu and also soft max
soft max is an activation function that
generates the output between 0 & 1 it
divides each output such that the total
sum of the outputs is equal to 1 it is
often used in the output layers softmax
L of the N equals E to L on the N over
the absolute value of e to the L so what
does this function mean I mean what is
actually going on here so we have our
output notes and our output notes are
giving us let's say they gave us 1.2 0.9
and 0.4 as a human being I look at that
and I say well the greatest value is 1.2
so whatever category that is we have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or let's say it's a cow and we had
cats and talks earlier why the cats and
dogs are hanging out with a cow I don't
know but we have a value and it might
say 1.2 is a cat point 9 is the dog and
point 4 is a cow for some reason it
stinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human I could look at one
point to and say this is definitely what
it is it's definitely a cat or whatever
it is maybe looking at different kinds
of cars might be a bidder whether it's a
car truck or motorcycle maybe I'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that may be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us
and so with the softmax we want all
those numbers to always add up to 1
so when I add three numbers together
with the final output to be one on there
and so it goes through this formula
changes each of these numbers in this
case it changes them to 0.46
0.34 and 0.20 they all add up to one and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than 1 it's never
gonna be less than zero and so you can
see here that there's probably a pretty
high chance that it's the first one so
you're a human being we have no problem
knowing that but this output can then
also go into say another input so it
might be an automated car that's picking
up image
as an image in front of us is probably a
big truck we should deal with it like
it's a big truck it's probably not a
motorcycle or whatever those categories
are that's the softmax part of it but
now we have the rail ooh well where's
the rail ooh coming from well the rail
ooh is what's generating the 1.2 and the
0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you remember
our rail uu stands for rectified linear
unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent age the step function
remember I said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a 0
or 1 but the rail ooh if you have that
as your output you know have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of X if X is positive and 0 otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between 0 or 1 and then the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
outputs usually a 1 or 0 and then the
other little piece of uncertainty there
that you can send forward to another
network or you can look at to know that
there's uncertainty involved and is
often used in the hidden layers this is
what's coming out of the hidden layer
Xin to the output layer usually or as we
reference the convolutional neural
network the CN n so you'd have to go to
another video to review the Ray Lu is
the most common used for convolutional
part of that network it has a bunch of
little pieces that are very simplified
looking at all the different images or
different sections of the map and the
Ray Lu works really good for that like I
said there's other formulas used but
this is the most common one and you'll
see that in the hidden layers going
maybe between one layer and the next
layer so just a quick recap we have our
softmax
which means that if you have numerous
categories only one of them is going to
be picked but you also want to have some
value attached to it how well it picked
it and you put them between 0 1 so it's
very standardized so we have our softmax
we looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
in numbers and then we have our rayleigh
function which takes the information in
the summation and puts it between a 0
and a 1 where it's either clearly a 0 or
pending on how confident our model is
it'll go between the 0 and 1
what are hyper parameters wow this is a
great interview question hyper
parameters when you are doing neural
networks this is what you're playing
with most of time once you've gotten the
data formatted correctly a hyper
parameter is a parameter whose value is
set before the learning process begins
determines how a network is trained and
the structure of the network this
includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hit layers are you
gonna have and how many nodes in each
layer learning rate learning rate is
usually multiplied once you've figured
out the error how much you want to
change the weights we talked about or I
mentioned it early just briefly you
don't want to just make a huge change
otherwise you're gonna have a biased
model so you only take some little
incremental changes and that's what the
learning rate is is a small incremental
changes epochs how many times are you
gonna go through all the data and your
training set so one epoch is one trip
through all the data and there's a lot
of other things depending on which model
you're working with and which
programming script you're working with
like the Python SK learn package will
have a slightly different than say
Google's tensor flow package which will
be a little bit different than the SPARC
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so then we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
can get an unbiased model or we can have
a better prediction on it that matches
our data closer what will happen if
learning rate is set too low or too high
we have a nice couple graphs here we
said one over yours as a learning rate
set to load you can see that it slowly
works its way down the curve and on the
right you can see a learning rate set to
high it's just bouncing back and forth
when your learning rate is too low as we
studied it two slides over that's what
the learning rate was training of the
model will progress very slowly as we
are making very tiny updates to the
weights well take many updates before
reaching the minimum point so I just
mentioned epic going through all the
data I might have to go through all the
data a thousand times instead of 500
times for it to Train learning rate too
high
causes undesirable divergent behavior to
the loss function due to drastic updates
and weights at
it may fail to converge or even diverge
so if you have your learning rate said
too high and it's training too quickly
maybe you'll get lucky and it trains
after one epic run but a lot of times it
might never be able to train because the
weights are changing too fast they flip
back and forth too easy and you see down
here we've introduced two new terms
converge and diverge a converge means
that our model has reached a point or
it's able to give a fairly good answer
for all the data we put in all those
weights have adjusted and it's minimized
the error diverge means that the data is
so chaotic that it could never manage to
to train to that data that is just too
chaotic for to Train so we have two new
words there converge and diverge are
important to know also what is dropout
and batch normalization dropout is a
technique of dropping out hidden and
visible units of a network randomly to
prevent overfitting of data it doubles
the number of iterations needed to
converge the network so here we have our
standard neural network and then after
applying dropout now it doesn't mean we
actually delete the note the note is
still there and we're still going to use
that note what it means is that we're
only going to work with a few of the
notes a lot of times I think the most
common one right now used is 20%
so you'll drop out 20% of the nodes when
you do your training you reverse
propagate your data and then you'll
randomly pick another 20 nodes the next
time you go through an epoch data
training so each time you go through one
epoch you will randomly pick 20 of those
nodes not to not to mess with and this
allows for less overfitting of the data
so by randomly doing this you create
some I guess it just kind of pulls some
nodes off to the sides and says we're
gonna handle the data later on so we
don't over fit batch normalization is
the technique to improve the performance
and stability of neural network
the idea is to normalize the inputs in
every layer so that they have mean
output and activation of zero in
standard deviation of one this question
covers a lot of different things which
is great it's a great interview question
because it pulls in that you have to
understand what the mean value is so a
mean output activation of zero that
means our average activation is zero
so when you normalize it remember we're
usually we're going between minus 1 and
1 on a lot of these it's a very standard
set
so you have to be very aware that this
is your meat output activation of zero
and then we have our standard deviation
of one so we want to keep our error down
to just a one value the benefits of this
doing a batch normalization is it
provides regularization it trains faster
higher learning rates and weights are
easier to initialize what is the
difference between batch gradient
descent and stochastic gradient descent
batch gradient descent batch gradient
computes the gradient using the entire
data set it takes time to converge
because the volume of data is huge and
weights updated slowly so you can look
at the batch as a lot of times if you're
using big data batch the data end but
you still go through a full epoch you
still go through all the data on there
so batch gradient descent means you're
gonna use it to fit all the data and
look for convergence there stochastic
gradient descent stochastic gradient
computes the gradient using a single
sample it converges much faster than
batch gradient because it updates weight
more frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when we model learns
the details and noise and the training
data to the degree that it adversely
impacts execution of the model on the
new from formation it is more likely to
occur with nonlinear models that have
more flexibility when learning a target
function an example of this would be if
you're looking at say cars and trucks
and motorcycles it might only recognize
trucks that have a certain box like
shape it might not be able to notice a
flatbed truck unless there's only a
specific kind of flatbed truck or only
for trucks because that's what it saw on
the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and rate on maybe a small test amount of
data but when you go to lose it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and start
and is not very functional outside of
your small area or your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
under fitting alludes to a model that is
neither well-trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model as a bird
performance and accuracy so if you're
using under fitted data and you generate
a model and you distribute that in a
commercial zone you'll have a lot of
people unhappy with you because it's not
going to
very good answers so we've explained
overfitting and underfitting so now we
want to ask how to combat them
combating overfitting and underfitting
resampling the data to estimate the
model accuracy k-fold cross-validation
having a validation data set to evaluate
the model so we do the resampling we're
randomly going to be picking out data
I'll run it a few times to see how that
works depending on our random data and
how we sample the data to generate our
model and then we want to go ahead and
validate the data set by having our
training data and then keeping some data
on the side testing data to validate it
how our weights initialized in an hour
initializing all weights to zero all the
weights are set to zero this makes your
model similar to a linear model so if
you have linear data coming in doing a
basic setup like that might work all the
neurons and every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a keyword it's gonna be useless if
you initialize everything to 0 at that
point be looking into some other machine
learning tools initializing all weights
randomly here the weights are assigned
randomly by initializing them very close
to 0 it gives better accuracy to the
model since every neuron performs
different computations and here we have
the weights are set randomly we have our
input layer the hidden layers and the
output layer and W equals NP random
random in layer size L layer size L
minus 1 this is the most commonly used
is to randomly generate your weights
what are the different layers in C n n
convolutional neural network first is
the convolutional layer that performs a
convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so and go into detail exactly
how the C the convolutional layer works
in the CN n as far as creating a number
of smaller picture windows to go over
the data the second step is as a
Rayleigh layer ray Lu brings
non-linearity to the network and
converts all the negative pixels to 0
output is rectified feature map so it
goes into a mapping feature there
pooling layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our Rayleigh layer which is
pulling all these little maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating a little
tiny neural net
to look at different parts of the
picture that we need to pull it together
and finally the fully connected layer so
we've flattened our pulling layer out
and we have a fully connected layer
recognizes and classifies the objects in
the image and that's actually your
forward propagation reverse propagation
training model usually there's number of
different models out there course what
is pooling and CNN and how does it work
pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a CNN performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix I mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the smaller
little neural network using the rail ooh
you look at it'll just kind of go over
the main picture and look at all the
different areas on the main picture so
you might step one two three four spaces
and then you have another one that's
also looking at features and it has a
275 each one of those is a map so it
might be the first one might be a map
looking for cat ears and the second one
looking for human eyes when it does this
you then have this rectified feature map
looking at these different features and
the max pooling with a two by two
filters and a strata two stride means
instead of skipping every pixel you're
gonna go every two pixels you take the
maximum values and you can see over here
we look at a pool feature map one of the
features says hey I had a max value of 8
so somewhere in here we saw a human I
labeled as 8 pretty high label and maybe
7 was a human hand and maybe 4 was cat
whiskers or something that we thought
might be cat whiskers 4 is kind of a low
number in this particular case compared
to the other ones so you have your full
pool feature map you can see the process
here is we have our stepping we look for
the max value and then we create a pool
feature map of the max values how does
ls TM network work that's long
short-term memory so the first thing to
know is that an LS TM s are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior we did
look at the Rio run in briefly talked
about how the hidden layer feeds back
into it
with the LS TM has a much more
complicated feedback and you can see
here we have the hidden layer of t minus
1 and hidden layer that's what the H
stands for hidden layer of T and the
formula is going in as we can see here
we have the hint layers we have t minus
1 and then H of T or T stands for time
so this is a series remember working
with series that we want to remember the
past and you can see you have your X
your input of T and that might be a
frame in a video as a frame comes in the
usually using this one the tangent a CH
activation formula but you also see that
it goes through a couple other formulas
the Omega formula and so when it
combines these that thing goes into the
next layer your next hidden layer that
thing goes into the data that's
submitted to the next input so you have
your X of T plus 1 so when you have that
coming in then you have your H value
that's coming forward from the last
process and depending on how many of
these Omega structures you put in there
depends on how long-term the memory gets
so it's important to remember this is
more for your long-term recurrent neural
networks the three steps in an LS TM
step one decides what to forget and what
to remember step two selectively update
cell state values so based on what we
want to remember and forget we want to
update those cell values and then
decides what part of the current state
make it to the output so now we have to
also have an output on there
what are vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question to
fix all our neural networks while
training an RNN your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in X and our change in Y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially it's a nice graph of that
here issues in gradient problem long
training time poor performance and low
accuracy what is the difference between
epic bat and iteration and deep learning
epic an epic represents one iteration
over the entire data set so that's
everything your
go ahead and put into that training
model batch we cannot pass the entire
data set into the neural network at once
so we divide the data set into a number
of batches and then iteration if we have
10,000 images as data and a batch size
of 200 then the epoch should run 10,000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iteration so in each epoch we're running
over all the data set we're gonna have
50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning
well first tensorflow provides both C++
and Python API s that makes it easier to
work on has a faster compilation time
than other deep learning libraries like
chorus and torch tensorflow
supports both cpus and gpus computing
devices so right now tensorflow is at
the top of the market because it's so
easy to use for both programmers side
and for hardware side and for the speed
of getting something up and running what
do you mean by tenser and tenser flow
tensor is a mathematical object
represented as a raise of higher
dimension these arrays of data with
different dimensions and ranks that are
fed as input to the neural network are
called tensors and you can see here we
have a tensor of dimensions 5 comma 4 so
it's a two dimensional tints are coming
in you could look at an image like this
at each one of those pixels is a
different value if it's a black and
white so it might be zero at once and
then each one represents a black and
white image in a color photo you might
either find a different value system or
you might have a tensor value that has
the XY coordinates as we see here plus
the colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images that are red the blue
and the yellow coming in and even as you
go from one layer or one tensor to the
next these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous the
case of the convergence neural network
we have all those smaller different
mappings of features that come in so
each one of those layers coming through
is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensor flow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use TF calm
instant command example a equals TF
constant 2.0 tf2 so it's a tensor float
value of 32 B equals TF constant 3.0
print a B if we did a print of a B we'd
have TF dot constant and then of course
B is an instance of it variables
variables allow us to add new trainable
parameters to graph to divide a variable
we use T f dot variable command and
initialize them before running the graph
in session example W equals TF variable
0.3 D type TF float 32 or B equals the
TF variable minus 3 comma D type float
32 placeholders placeholders allow us to
feed data to a tensorflow model from
outside a model it permits a value to be
assigned later to define a placeholder
we use TF placeholder command example a
equals TF placeholder B equals a times 2
with the TF session as a CSS result
equals session run become a feed
dictionary equals a 3.0 print result we
have a nice example they replace holder
session a session is run to evaluate the
notes this is called as the tensorflow
runtime so for example you have a equals
TF constant 2.0 B equals TF constant 4.0
C equals a plus B and at this point
you'd go ahead and create a session
equals TF session and then you could
evaluate these tensor C print session
run C input C as an input into your
session what do you understand by a
computational RAF everything in
tensorflow is based on creating a
computational graph it has a network of
nodes where each node performs an
operation nodes represent mathematical
operation and edges represent tensors
since data flows in a form of a graph it
is also called a data flow graph and we
have a nice visual of this graph or
graphic image of a computational graph
and you can see here we have our input
nodes our add multiply nodes and or
multiply node at the end and then we
have the edges where the data flows so
we have from a going to see a going to D
can see we have a two flowing four
flowing explained generative adversarial
Network along with an example suppose
there is a wine shop that purchases wine
from dealers which they will resell
later
so we're dealer going to the wine our
shop owner that
sells it for a profit but there are some
mal factor dealers who sell fake wine in
this case the shop owner should be able
to distinguish between fake and
authentic wine the Forge will try two
different techniques to sell fake wine
and make sure certain techniques go past
the shop owners check so here's a forger
fake wine shop owner the shop owner
would probably get some feedback from
the wine experts that some of the wine
is not original the owner would have to
improve how he determines whether a wine
is fake or authentic goal a forger to
create wines that are indistinguishable
from the authentic ones goal of shop
owner to accurately tell if the wine is
real or not
there are two main components of
generative adversarial Network we refer
to as a noise vector coming in where we
have our forger who's going to generate
fake wine and then we have our real
authentic wine and of course our shop
owner has to figure out whether it's
real or fake the generator is a CNN the
keys producing images and are closer in
appearance to the real images while the
discriminator tries to determine the
difference between real and fake images
the ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator to learn to identify real
and fake images what is an autoencoder
the network is trained to reconstruct
its inputs it is a neural network that
has three layers here the input neurons
are equal to the output neuron the
network's target outside is same as the
input it uses dimensionality reduction
to restructure the input input image
comes in we have our Latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works kind
of compressing the input to a Latin
space representation and then
reconstructing the output from this
representation
what is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting our ensemble techniques where
the idea is to Train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're gonna have our
training data and our test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bagged one model one bag two model
two bag three model three and so on in
boosting the emphasis is to select the
data points which give wrong output in
order to improve the accuracy so in
boosting we have our data set again we
split it to test data and train data
bag one and we'll train the model data
points with wrong predictions and go
into bag two and we then train that
model and repeat so we've covered a
number of questions that you might get
during an interview hopefully this helps
you get land that perfect job we want to
thank you for joining us here at simply
learn again WW simply learn comm get
certified get ahead we have a number of
other resources out there so if you want
to learn more about the RNN recurrent
neural network or the CNN the
convolutional neural network is one of
the main things we have a tensor flow
out there you can come and research a
number of other YouTube videos or come
visit us for more information at
www.clickincomputer.com